bonsoir madame merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france 3000 suspension
nous a annoncé le ministre de la santé
ce matin de soignants dron vacciner vous
comprenez ces soignants mécontent que
l'on vient d'entendre
bah oui tout à fait moi j'ai jamais
entendu autant de deux mots violents
pour
[Musique]
envers les soignants je comprends pas ce
qui se passe c'est vraiment ça ce sont
que des mots comme se justifier des
sanctions des contrôles
vous êtes interdit de pratiquer la
médecine enfin on n'a jamais entendu ça
c'est dans la bouche d'un état c'est
c'est incompréhensible
un état aux poutrelles et doit être un
peu d'empathie un peu de remerciement on
a on applaudit tous les soignants
l'année dernière et puis maintenant on
les vire mais je laisse ça dépasse mon
entendement
je ne peux pas comprendre surtout bon on
était au front les premiers moi même
j'ai attrapé le coc vite parce que
j'avais pas de masse que l'année
dernière
donc je comprends pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui on me vire moi ça y est j'ai
arrêté mon activité hier je laisse 1500
patients sur le trottoir
c'est incompréhensible alors que j'avais
rien à jouer au docteur roger à votre
situation évidemment on partait de ces
soignants et vous en faites partie vous
faites partie de ces soignants justement
ces médecins qui ne serait pas se faire
vacciner qu'est ce qui s'est passé
clairement on vous a dit fermer votre
cabinet racontez nous
mais on a reçu une lettre de la rs en
plein mois d'août avec que des mots
violents et disons que de toute façon au
15 septembre il fallait fermer sinon on
était menacée de sanctions pénales
pénale c'est-à-dire selon le l'article
de la loi six mois de prison dix mille
euros damende mais c'est complètement
incompréhensible moi j'arrive pas d'un
toit contre encore pu s'adresser à nous
comme ça
bah écoutez puisque moi je ne comprends
plus du tout ce genre de médecine là
c'est complètement hors de mes hommes du
mois sur une médecine et hind écoute je
comprends pas qu'on puisse être traité
comme ça bah ils veulent plus de moi bah
je m'en vais voilà c'est dramatique pour
mes patients pardonnez moi vous
justement vous en avait parlé avec vos
patients du fait que nous n'avez pas
envie de vous faire vacciner qu'est-ce
qui vous répondent eux
c'est très très variable en fait c'est
pas vraiment que j'ai pas envie c'est
que j'ai pas besoin il ya toute une
partie de la population qui a été
complètement occulté c'est tous les gens
qui ont fait le colis qui ont des
anticorps moi j'ai toujours d'un
anticorps je le vérifie de temps en
temps moi j'estime qu'il sera pris en
médecine que quand on avait des
anticorps on se remet va ce qui n'est
pas derrière or là on est dans une folie
vaccinale on vaccine des gens qui ont
des anticorps quelques choix énorme
énorme on sait pas ce que ça te de mes
clients ça ça n'a pas de raison d'être
j'ai été alerté par une dame son fils à
ulcos gide un adolescent il a des
anticorps énormes qui sont même plus
durable ses supérieurs à 250 et bien ce
jeune là qu'est tout à fait protéger et
pas du tout dangereux eh bien il a droit
à rien il n'a pas droit à son pass
sanitaires il faut qu'il soit vacciné
mais c'est là où je dis on est dans une
folie vaccinale la chine et des gens ou
des anticorps c'est une aberration et je
pense qu'on est des millions on est des
millions en france
l'argument l'argument qui consiste à
dire qui ressort évidemment dans ce
débat sensible c'est de dire là on se
vaccine pas nécessairement pour soi même
mais aussi et surtout pour les autres
pour ne pas contaminer peut-être des
personnes fragiles autour de soi qu'est
ce que vous répondez vous à cela
écoutez plus que j'ai des anticorps non
seulement je suis protégé mais je
protège les autres ça c'est une évidence
il ya avant de fermer la g j'ai
rencontré un patient qui avait été
vacciné de choix
et qui jouit dans les anticorps comme ça
pour voir parce que c'est quand même
récente savament aussi ce qui se passe
sur le terrain et ce monsieur avait zéro
anticorps pourquoi parce qu'il avait une
maladie auto immune ils n'avaient pas
développé des anticorps ainsi disait
monsieur vous voyez le paradoxe dont
vous avez votre place vous pouvez aller
où vous voulez vous vous croyez protéger
donc peut-être que vous faites moins
d'attention et vous l'êtes pas du tout
et moi qui suis enfin de vous je suis
protégé je suis pas dangereuse
mais pas transmettre aux ide si vous
avez des anticorps parce qu'on nous dit
régulièrement le contraire qu'on peut
tout de même être porteur et le
transmettre y compris quand on a des
anticorps et non on peut être vaccinés
et et le transmettre mais avoir des
anticorps du manque mais mon masque
normalement normalement c'est bon mangez
des dents plus cossus ses protégés se
protège avec le maersk ces bons points
mais alors que quand on nous dit tous
vaccinés tous protégés là c'est pas tout
à fait vrai parce que bon dans cette
crise aussi on n'est jamais allé
demander ce que les médecins
généralistes disait
mais moi j'ai vu énormément de coliposte
vaccination
en tout cas
on vous aura d'année nous la parole en
direct sur sur rt france merci véronique
roger médecins dont généralistes merci
d'avoir été avec nous